foreign
[Music]
New York office is packed with
technology there's Tech that tracks
there's 5 000 individual data points
that are being constantly collected and
harvested in this facility and Tech used
for collaboration is there any space in
this office that doesn't have a camera
no there isn't Cisco's smart office is
both the Showcase of the company's
technology and an example of how it sees
the workplace evolving so how does it
look and more importantly how does it
work I took a tour with the Project's
leaders and popped into a few meetings
to find out
Cisco's 59 000 square foot office sits
in Midtown Manhattan and one Penn Plaza
exactly where it's been for the last 17
years
but in the last two it's undergone an 18
million dollar Tech driven redesign this
is one of the few projects where
technology was really at the very
beginning and pervasive throughout the
entire process in this space the screens
cameras and sensors came before the
lighting and Furniture which was a new
process for both Gensler and Cisco we
really think technology is going to be
at the heart of how people design
buildings moving forward so we started
it with that layer to see this Tech all
you have to do is look up the ceiling is
littered with tech Each of which doing
more than it might appear it's not hard
to miss this camera what does this
camera do actually this was a Meraki
security camera and obviously it's
recording people coming in and out of
the floor but it's also got a trip wire
built in we can actually count people as
they come in and decrement as they leave
so at any given time we know the overall
occupancy of the floor but to know where
people are after they enter the office
Cisco uses its wireless access points
like this one it's actually traffic
tracking mobile devices as a proxy for
understanding occupancy of space and
people but it's also tracking air
quality temperature and humidity is it
tracking my mobile device right yeah
it's tracking a mobile device it doesn't
know it's you but it knows there are two
mobile devices here because I have one
in my pocket as well leave the hallway
to enter a meeting and the cameras used
to connect employees on video call then
pick up the count tracking the number of
participants in the room
while employees may be anonymous this
type of tracking isn't common just one
percent of companies in a 2022 Gartner
poll have sensors that track foot
traffic 43 percent of companies say they
aren't tracking on-site attendance at
all our employees at all concerned about
the tracking that's possible in an
office where cameras count the number of
bodies in the space no I don't believe
they are and the reason and for that is
at Cisco we don't have a set number of
days that we expect employees to be in
the office I think if we had different
expectations around being in the office
it may feel a little bit different but
because we don't I think they understand
that those insights allow us to make the
space the best that it can be for them
still these are Cisco products other
companies that purchase these systems
could use them for more specific
tracking or they could do as Cisco does
and feed the data here for employees to
see really what we have here is the
great ability to show employees space
availability red is obviously a space
that is booked and being used right now
or Amber is a space that's booked and
not being used and green is an available
space let's find a space that we can go
yeah so so here's the space right here
let's
we'll go to the space okay
let's hold that and that's going to give
us four minutes to get over there four
minutes because in this office space is
meant to be shared so rooms like the
ones lining this Hall aren't bookable
the red and green lights are your signal
see this is our room that we're going to
use yep
it's ad hoc spaces represent one of the
biggest changes to Cisco's space how
it's balanced take a look at Cisco's
floor plan these spaces are what Cisco
considers individual workspaces these
spaces are for teams in the past our
building was set up where seventy
percent of the space was targeted toward
individuals and 30 of the space was
targeted to our teams and we flipped
that that resulted in the 90
collaboration spaces seen here and left
just 50 individual desks I think this is
a new era and I think that when you want
to sit by yourself and get work done you
may not choose the office to do that
there are actually about 1700 employees
assigned to this office but Cisco
doesn't expect that they'll all be in on
the same day with hybrid here to stay
we're seeing so much more emphasis on
amenity spaces collaboration spaces
people are coming in to be with other
people the things that they can't do
when they're working at home things like
brainstorming on a whiteboard or meeting
in a 14-person room like this one are
now the focus so what's really
interesting about this space is how the
space design how the furnishings and the
technology all come together they come
together because Cisco designed the
table to work specifically with the
camera at the other end from the
placement of the microphones to this
matte finish which helps reflect light
up onto the faces of the table most
noticeable though is the table's tapered
shape we shape the table to make sure
everybody has a line of sight on the
display all right and can see content
and we also have make sure that people
that are remote
that are joining us actually have line
of sight of everybody at the table right
because that person all the way at the
end is much further to the right than I
am so they should be able to see every
single face down the road that shape and
the exclusion of chairs on the screen
side is pervasive in Cisco space because
it says 98 of its meetings will have a
remote participant so who is this
conference room designed for is it
designed for the people who are here at
this table or is it designed for the
people who are signing in remotely when
we think about designing collaboration
spaces like this we spend as much time
if not more about worrying about the
remote participant we want to make sure
there's absolute digital equality
digital equality that's an idea that
Cisco stressed and something it thinks
it's hybrid Workforce needs something
that we have all experienced is
sometimes you're in a meeting and you're
having a hard time breaking in and
especially if you happen to be the only
one in the office or the only one
working remotely and here's where the
camera can help bring people or at least
their faces closer I tested it with
colleagues who work in two separate
offices are you seeing this this full
room are you seeing this whole table
no I'm seeing four Traders same I just
sent you a screen grab oh okay yeah yeah
so it's really you're really only seeing
like my my side of the room
there is an argument to be made that
with all of Cisco's technology and the
ability to make every space into a
hybrid meeting space that the office
isn't really needed at all what would
you say to that well I think the at the
end of the day people will want to come
together but they're going to come
together for different reasons but for
those who'd rather stay home the tech is
here to support that and that's an
example that other companies may follow
so do you expect other companies you
work with to want to do Tech first
design second absolutely I mean so many
of our clients are interested in seeing
this space because of how this was built
I think anyone that's looking to build a
new space is going to think this way
foreign